a analizar entonces la política tanto
interna como la externa del gobierno de
johnson comencemos con dos temas
principales de esta política interna
primero hablemos de la situación con
escocia su deseo de independencia como
queda esto tras la salida de johnson
primero que nada muchísimas gracias por
su invitación para mí es un placer estar
acá la situación con escocia viene
siendo tensa sobre todo después lo que
fue el presi es 23 de junio de 2016
desde entonces teniendo en cuenta que
escocia se sintió desoída frente a que
se quería quedar dentro de la unión
europea las idas y vueltas entre
westminster y escocia no han sido
fáciles de hecho en el día de ayer
boris johnson en uno de sus últimos
actos como primer ministro rechazó un
pedido de referéndum un referéndum
vinculante que la primera ministra de
escocia
solicitaba para hacerlo en la manera
correcta por decirlo así para que
durante el año siguiente es el 2023
escocia pudiera tener un nuevo
referéndum para consultarle al pueblo la
posibilidad e independencia recordemos
que el referendo una anterior fue el
2014 por la salida del reino unido y en
el kelme entonces ganó el no 'hoy por
hoy' entonces para extorsión debería
esperar a que se articuló un nuevo
gobierno y en todo caso poder negociar
ya nuevamente con el gobierno central la
posibilidad de que se les permite hacer
este gobierno y pues teniendo en cuenta
que va a ser un gobierno conservador
pues las cosas no es que puedan cambiar
a mucho no de acuerdo con la solicitud
que harían y con esto yo pero pues vamos
a ver qué va a pasar a cómo lo dices
indiana ahora hablemos también del éxito
una de sus consecuencias del protocolo
de irlanda del norte otro punto
pendiente que deja johnson
la situación en irlanda del norte
también es particularmente sensible
sobre todo porque
pensamos que en los últimos tiempos
boris johnson había intentado hacer unas
negociaciones de manera unilateral con
el reino unido- en colon europeas que de
alguna forma genera muchísima atención
entre lo que es la frontera de irlanda e
irlanda del norte
recordemos que recién en el 98 ellos
acuerdan lo que es el acuerdo de paz
entre las dos las dos irlandas y estos
acuerdos unilaterales por parte del
reino unido- lo que hacían era de alguna
forma alterar esa pasa alcanzada en los
últimos años de hecho el primer ministro
irlandés pedía que este nuevo gobierno
que se formará a partir de ahora con la
división de boris johnson tuviera en
cuenta a todos los actores porque para
ellos es fundamental mantener la paz con
los vecinos recordemos que con esta
salida o irlanda del norte queda por
fuera de la unión europea mientras que
el territorio irlandés
todavía formaba parte de lo que generaba
tensiones particularmente para el
movimiento de personas y el movimiento
comercial
y hablando ya para finalizar nuestra
conversación de la relación que deja
johnson precisamente con la unión
europea
la cito la verdad que ninguno de los
escenarios es muy favorable de hecho
quien asuma el cargo próximo primer
ministro o primera ministra va a
encontrarse con lo que han sido los
problemas de relación entre bruselas y
londres por los sucesivos intentos de
renegociación que hubo en los acuerdos
finales libres y de hecho yo creo que
para quien asuma el cargo le van a tocar
varios dolores de cabeza para tratar de
normalizar esta situación sobre todo
entendiendo que desde bruselas ya no hay
interés en negociar nada más de acuerdo
a lo que fue este período tan largo de
salida del reino unido de la unión
europea como decíamos que arrancó con el
referéndum del 2016 pensemos que es 2021
y todavía esto es un tema en vilo no
pareciera que al próximo el próximo
primer ministro primer ministro sea una
situación fácil de resolver